What will life be like
in a early Mars colony?
ROGER LAUNIUS: Let's take
some stages in terms of how
we might do things on Mars.
There is exploration, somebody
going out and coming back.
The next stage would be some
sort of research station.
We will mostly
resupply it from Earth.
You cycle people in and
out on a regular basis.
I would contend that that would
look a lot like Antarctica.
You don't have to
fly into space,
obviously, to go to Antarctica.
But it's not easy to get to.
And it's not easy to
sustain life there.
NARRATOR: At the very
bottom of the world,
there's a cheerless land where
the long night is 125 degrees
below 0 and murderous winds
howl at 200 miles an hour
across a desert as
desolate as the moon.
CHARLES ELACHI: Before we used
to send people to Antarctica,
they crossed the
Antarctic continent
and came back and waited
three, four years before you
sent the next expedition.
NARRATOR: Then in
1954, a dozen nations
decided to man 50 stations
built around the continent.
Now, the emphasis
shifted to science.
CHARLES ELACHI:
Today, you literally
have hundreds of people who
actually live in the station
throughout the year.
JOSEPH LEVY: There are
more scientists working
in Antarctica today
from more different
countries than there probably
have ever been in the past.
And what that means
is, globally, we
need to think about how
we collaborate and manage
and work together.
I think it's a
good model for how
policy and engineering and
politics can come together
to produce great science.
JOHN BRUNSFELD:
The McMurdo Station
is a kind of analog to
the kind of activity
we hopefully want to do on
Mars someday because McMurdo
is, in fact, a city.
This is where you have
infrastructure, where you have
power, where you have supplies.
BK GRANT: We have
everything from people
who cook the food to people
who prepare science cargo.
We all live and work together.
And we have
essentially one goal.
And that is to
support the science.
DAVID DINGES: What
happens in the Antarctic
is what will likely
happen on Mars.
We'll create a kind of
early version of community.
And what we really want to do
is make sure that we understand
how humans can cope with
the next level of risk
living on Mars, trying
to feed everybody,
and coping with
different visions
of what should happen next.
And that's going to require
a much different level of
understanding how to do this.
We'll get there.
We just got to move
to it in steps.